hey everyone how's it going
welcome to the Stream
this is just going to be a quick stream
as I don't have a lot of time right now
um but I did want to kind of go through
the character creation with you guys and
uh give you a glimpse into Hogwarts
Legacy
[Music]
hello hello I'll just let uh everyone
kind of Pile in and then I'll get going
soon
hey everyone welcome back to another
installment of Hogwarts Legacy
okay let's create this uh let's start
creating this character
give me a uh W in the chat if um if
you've played already
I don't love speaking without a script
we are pleased to inform you that you've
been accepted at Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry as a fifth year
student term begins on the 1st of
September preliminary supplies have been
collected for you and will accompany you
on your journey to the castle as you may
be aware the decree for the reasonable
restriction of underage sorcery
prohibits the use of Magic by those
under the age of 17 outside school
however due to your unique circumstances
the ministry has graciously agreed to
allow Professor Eleazar fig to help you
hone your spell casting before escorting
you from London to the castle for the
starter term feast and the Sorting
ceremony yours sincerely
Professor Weasley deputy headmistress
[Music]
this is the uh deluxe version
who else has played let me know in the
chat
[Music]
foreign
thanks for the super chat
um yeah I mean that's the plan I've I
kind of started a separate profile
um just testing out the game but the
plan was to start a new character for
live streaming so I should be playing
the game through
um I'm not sure on uh stream frequency
yet but uh at least once one to two
times a week I think
foreign
[Music]
I might be evil we'll see I think that's
probably how I'll end up going for those
of you who've played uh Knights of the
Old Republic you know how it is
foreign
this one
[Music]
uh this is not live on Twitch
I'm still quite new to streaming so you
guys are gonna have to bear with me
I uh
half the time
don't know when the chats are coming
through if I need to I need to configure
the settings
wow
he looks tired
do that
it's kind of cool
it's a good one
yeah so if I if I miss your message
try sending it again
I just hit uh Finn
he's gone
so the more I uh the more I stream the
more comfortable I'll get at this and
the less uh boring it'll be probably
I'm still at that point where I'm
focusing on the Logistics of everything
working properly
and again today I'm just I'm just going
to be streaming and going through the
intro
um I will be streaming a lot more uh in
about three or four days I'm just going
away for a couple of days
yeah anger eyebrows I think
I'm eager to get to hogsmead
interesting voice
I am indeed a student but I could very
well be able to that was quite something
it was wonderful I believe I'm really
going to enjoy this class
just uh removed Machiavelli
what do I name him leave some uh
comments for the name here
no I didn't import my profile um I might
do another video doing that but uh not
not today
it's a really cool feature though
first name comment what I should name
him first name
foreign
he looks like a bit of an Arnold John
okay jar jar
is is that first name jar last name jar
or jar jar something
what's his last name
and jar jar Potter
I've got one
jar jar gaunt
okay let's uh let's kick off
it's jar jar sorry about that ah it
appears
to depart
it's a Pity we didn't have a bit more
time to spend on spell casting I presume
you've been practicing the Spells we
worked I have professor
I'm quite sure I'd never seen anyone
take so quickly to a second hand if
you're enjoying the stream please be
sure to give it a like helps the channel
oh Elias are George glad my rather
cryptic description of our location did
not thought you're finding us I've
apparated to more vaguely to find
destinations than this I'll review the
chat after this stream and um I'll set
some mods gave quite the Fright to some
theater goes in the West End
when I received Doral I must say I best
not speak here Elias are
of course
why don't we speak on route to Hogwarts
we have a start of term feasterness I'm
going to review all the comments of the
stream afterwards so if you have uh
doesn't mind me tagging along video
requests
leave them there
[Music]
foreign
for my voice in the game is it okay
okay
so I didn't have a PlayStation 5. I'm
playing this on PS5 I got a PlayStation
4 this game
so I'm complete PlayStation
[Music]
thanks midnight observed
the soundtrack for this game is amazing
just the heavy
and who is your traveling companion
a new student
new
yes sir I'm starting school as a fifth
year
how extraordinary it is indeed none of
the faculty has ever heard of anyone
being admitted to Hogwarts so late nor
have I of course as the other 50 years
will have been honing their magical
skills for four years now the Headmaster
asked if I could get her new student up
to speed a bit before the term begins
well you couldn't have asked for a
better Mentor Professor fig is not only
an exceptional teacher he's also a
remarkably intuitive and gifted
Mr ozric is prone to flattery I dare say
it's one of the reasons he's risen so
far at the ministry
have you seen scenes oh my God it's me
I have
opinions differ as to how great a threat
Round Rock really is the voicing
although I've yet is not great that's
one thing about character customization
I did not like there aren't enough
options
and and the voice levels just sound
strange
days like months ago Miriam
but otherwise quite comprehensive
she wrote to me about
before she died
wondering what the ministry knew about
his activities
before I could respond I yeah it sounds
robotic receive this
it was the last thing she sent me
earlier it came to me via her owl
but as I said this is going to be a
short stream so probably another 10
minutes 15 minutes
but I will stream for long periods
um early next week whatever magic
protects this is powerful indeed it
looks like Goblin metal
it's that glow
I don't see it thanks the one
[Music]
Misa God
how did you wait
I'm playing on uh PS5
I'm streaming through my PC
foreign
George didn't last long but can I get an
rip George in the chat
pay respects to George
yeah that's a great Point really it's
really cool with the festival it's wig
and weld potion that stuff will write
you in a second
Wigan weld potion
what happened
poor George
I can't believe he
what the hell got into that damn thing
Wigan world is the antidote to the uh
draft of sleeping death
professor
I wish character customization in games
was better voice would be based on a
sample of your own voice yeah
but that key you discovered was clearly
a old key
an item Enchanted to bring whoever
touches it to a specific place
I'm feeling better sir if you'd like to
look around a bit
I would
but stay close
we've no idea who created this Porky
oh why
how far did that Porky take us farther
from London than the carriage traveled
somewhere in the Scottish Highlands so
the ruins
the porky was meant to lead us there I
do this has not been the day either of
us expected but Miriam sent that four
key to George for a reason
and I believe I'm playing on a console
yeah I'm playing on a PS5 George died in
prison
if you're sure you're all right and
wouldn't mind indulging me I'd like to
have a look around absolutely sir good
let's see if we can find a path however
faded it may be
rip George
as I uh dig deeper into the game too
I'll do uh lore videos on the main
Channel
because this is Canada
Miriam spent years searching for
evidence of a long forgotten form of
ancient Magic
thank you
thank you yes a powerful magic wielded
by a rare few the
SE two have been lost to time
Hogwarts Castle was built by and is
itself a stronghold of that ancient
Magic
I don't know where she came into
possession of the fort key
but I am certain it was to do with that
search
that's the part down below this way
foreign
wanted to understand why such powerful
magic disappeared from The Wizarding
World spoke of the good it could do
but magic is no different than any power
what really matters is the one who
wields it
is that ice it's not cold enough here
it appears to be a sort of enchantment
someone wanted to block this path
let's see some of that one work you were
practicing
focus on the center
excellent
foreign
yeah it's kind of one deviation away
from Canon it's close like it'll be fun
to talk about in you know in terms of
law deeper law but
the more I play the more I'll be able to
understand if it's
breaching Cannon
oh up there
beta Cannon
we're close now it's just ahead
how uh how popular do you guys think
this game is going to be
is this like temporary hype or is this
gonna stay for a while I think it's
gonna stay for a while
my favorite game of all time is uh
Knights of the Old Republic
it's not turn based but it's
seems to be quite similar
yeah I haven't seen any anyone say
anything bad about it
oh big Couture fan yeah it's my favorite
game of all time
foreign
and I think this is the first Harry
Potter game they've really done right
like I've played some of the old ones on
consoles but
thank you for a reason let's have a look
around for anything that seems
out of place
Star Wars is uh is
theories domain
no not mine
gotta smash the pods
huh
Professor this statue this may have been
his home
which uh I'll see you guys in
leave a comment
if any slytherins in the chat oh yeah
okay
what's wrong
have you guys done all the quizzes on
Wizarding World
could it be blocking
what's this
Professor fig
how odd
that signature gringott's floor
no I didn't connect my my Pottermore
account
um I'll probably do that with a separate
Merlin's name
roderick's heart
where are we
I don't believe it
I know this game quite heavily explores
the goblin rebellions and I've actually
done a video on all of the separate
Goblin rebellions over the course of
history so you guys should check that
out
hello
no Professor fig isn't the Ghost the
ghost is um Cuthbert Benz who's the
history of magic teacher but he's in
this actually
I think yeah
[Music]
no that's not a spoiler
it can't be
in just a moment
oh
welcome to Gringotts Wizarding Bank
Vault number 12 I presume
[Music]
the White's Pokey oh yes of course
this way then
as I said earlier stopping the stream
soon but I'm gonna keep an eye out for
uh future streams as I'm going to be
streaming one to two times a week
probably only gonna be
um
I'm only gonna be playing it when I'm
streaming too so you get to see the
whole story
big if you recognize the name fig it's
because
um
Harry's neighbor
on privet Drive Arabella fig
who witnessed the dementor attack
how many votes are there
hundreds in fact you'll see quite a few
on our way to vote number 12. as we
speak we're just beneath the main lobby
now are the newest a private entrances
to the bank common at Gringotts
they are most uncommon only one with
great I'll probably uh yeah I'll
probably generally stream around this
time
I'll try to put some schedule together
and post it on the uh
or I'll just schedule them in advance
I've got to go so I'm gonna stop I think
what's this um
they are green box was founded over four
centuries ago
settling with quite a distance to go if
you do enjoy the streams make sure to
give it a like
vote number
thanks for the recommendation Azu
yeah I'm not controlling anything
not since I got on the card
thanks Lily Ben
like the clue you saw on the 4K
container but darker I saw that same
glow in the dragon's color yeah what was
that we were just wondering about that
Goblin back there did he watches over
the oldest section of the bank
rare anyone goes there anymore
here we are uh oh
okay well I guess I'll end this now and
uh and look into it I'll uh when was the
last time this vote was accessed that's
weird has been stationed at my desk for
hundreds of
in that time no one has visited vault
12. until today okay I'll be back soon
guys okay